>> Juan: THE 2020 BATTLE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND JOE BIDEN IS
HEATING UP AGAINST THE BACKDROP
OF CIVIL UNREST IN AMERICA.
TRUMP IS ACCUSING BIDEN’S
CAMPAIGN STAFF OF HELPING TO
GET -- I’M QUOTING -- ANARCHISTS
OUT OF JAIL.
MEANWHILE, JOE BIDEN IS SLAMMING
THE PRESIDENT TODAY OVER HIS
RESPONSE TO THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC AND ITS EFFECT IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
>> THE BAND AID HAS BEEN RIPPED
OFF BY THIS PANDEMIC AND THIS
PRESIDENT.
NOBODY CAN PRETEND ANY LONGER
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
NOBODY CAN PRETEND WHO HAS BEEN
CARRYING THIS ON OUR BACK.
IT’S MINORITIES, BLACK,
HISPANICS.
>> Juan: GREG, LET’S START WITH
YOU.
WHEN THE BIDEN PEOPLE WERE
GIVING DONATIONS, IT’S TO BAIL
OUT NONVIOLENT PROTESTERS.
PEOPLE IN THE TRADITION OF
DR. KING.
THEY SEE THIS TWITTER THING AND
THEY SAY HE’S BAILING OUT
MURDERISTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: IF YOU’RE POSTING BAIL
SIGHT UNSEEN, YOU’RE NOT SURE
WHO YOU’RE BAILING OUT.
ARE YOU BAILING OUT THE PEOPLE
THAT TORCHED A BAR OR THE WOMAN
THAT WAS BEATEN WITH STICKS?
YOU MAY KNOW NOT WHO YOU’RE
BAILING OUT.
IT’S EASY FOR CELEBRITIES LIKE
CHRISTY TEIGEN TO POST BAIL FROM
A GATED COMMUNITY WHERE SHE WILL
NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A
THREAT IN HER LIFE.
SHE ACTUALLY WAS A SPOKESPERSON
FOR TARGET.
I GUESS SHE’S MAKING TARGET A
TARGET.
>> Juan: DANA, HOW DO YOU THINK
JOE BIDEN IS DOING?
YOU SAW HIM THERE AT THE CHURCH.
>> Dana: LAST WEEK IS THE FIRST
TIME WE’VE SEEN HIM LEAVE.
I THINK THAT EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
AWARE AND I THINK WE ARE, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT, MAYBE WE
HAVEN’T DONE ENOUGH, BUT WE KNOW
THIS STATISTICS OF THE PEOPLE,
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE DIED OR BEEN EFFECTED BY
CORONAVIRUS.
WE KNOW THEM.
I BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS SEVERAL TIMES.
BUT PERHAPS WE NEED TO DO MORE
IN THAT AREA.
I DON’T LIKE IT WHEN YOU HAVE A
CRISIS LET ALONE THREE CRISES
ALL AT ONCE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR.
I THINK WE’RE ABOUT FIVE MONTHS
AWAY ON WEDNESDAY FROM ELECTION
DAY.
SO THERE’S GOING TO BE POLITICS,
MESSY.
FOR THE PRESIDENT, TO STAY
MISSION FOCUSED AS DEALING WITH
THESE AND THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND AND RESTORING LAW AND
ORDER AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
FOURTH BILL GETS DONE AND GETS
TO THE PEOPLE LIKE THE ONE GREG
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT, THE MAN
THAT LOST HIS BAR.
HE GOT A PPE LOAN AND NOW HE
DOESN’T HAVE ANYBODY TO GO BACK
TO.
A LOT OF THIS IS COMPLEX AND WE
OUGHT TO APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Juan: GOOD POINT.
JESSE, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT -- I WAS ASKING DANA ABOUT
HOW BIDEN IS DOING.
HOW IS TRUMP DOING?
TODAY WITH THE GOVERNOR THING,
GET TOUGH, TAKE CONTROL.
THE EARLIER TWEET ABOUT WHEN THE
LOOTING STARTS, THE SHOOTING
STARTS.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT IS
PROVOCATIVE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
COMMENTS?
>> Jesse: WHAT I THINK IS THAT
HE’S GETTING BLAMED FOR TWEETS
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE DOING NOTHING
WHILE CITIES BURN.
I’M LOOKING AT ACTION RIGHT NOW.
TRUMP IS TAKING ACTION.
HE ACTIVATED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
HE CONDEMNED THE RIOTS.
HE SAYING HEY, GOVERNORS, THE
NATIONAL GUARD IS ON STAND BY
WAITING FOR THE CALL TO COME IN.
LET’S GO.
WHAT MORE DO THE GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS NEED?
EVERYBODY IS GETTING THEIR BUTT
KICKED ALL OVER THE STREETS.
YOU HAVE WOMEN, STORE OWNERS,
GETTING THEIR CLOCKS CLEANED IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT BY STREET
CRIMINALS AND TRUMP’S THE TARGET
BECAUSE HE TWEETED SOMETHING?
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME.
JOE BIDEN DOESN’T KNOW WHAT HE
DOING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THEY’RE GOING TO OH, I’M ONLY
GOING TO MAKE ONE MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL AND LOOK AT TRUMP’S
TWEET AND MAKE TWO.
DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Juan: JUDGE JEANINE, I WAS
WONDERING WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT BIDEN IN DELAWARE
WENT TO SEE SOME OF THE
PROTESTERS AND STOOD WITH THEM.
YOU THINK THAT WAS A GOOD
GESTURE?
LOOK, IT’S A GOOD THING.
THERE’S COPS THAT WERE TAKING A
KNEE NOW, WHO ARE HUGGING
PROTESTERS.
THERE’S COPS THAT ARE OUTRAGED
BY WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD
HERE.
IT’S NICE FOR JOE BIDEN TO
COMPLAIN AND HE COMES OUT TO PUT
A WREATH ON AND TALK TO THE
FAMILY.
I BELIEVE IT’S A FAMILY, THE
BROTHER OF GEORGE FLOYD.
THAT’S GOOD.
OTHER THAN THAT, ALL JOE BIDEN
IS DOING IS TALKING.
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING WHAT
AMERICANS ARE THINKING, WHICH IS
GET OUT THERE, DO SOMETHING,
STOP THE VIOLENCE, STOP THE
AMERICANS FROM HAVING TO SUFFER
MORE PAIN AND MORE ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION.
HE’S BEING A LEADER.
JOE BIDEN IS PROBABLY GOING BACK